attention vous n'êtes pas toi c'est
ainsi que commence la grande aventure de
ma petite sarraf
je dois tu es à moi de ma personne un
jour viendra où nos chemins se
croiseront pas ce que tu fais tu emmènes
ou
c'est très bien qu'on arrive à
alexandrie tu prends la première
caravane et tu rentres chez toi
le pacha sera
pas faire un peu
bouka d'aucun cas d'où nous en aux
arabes en france petit test
le mc du raf j'ai promis à sa mère de
veiller sur elle l'asmo à partir avec ça
va pas la tête mais je voudrais qu'on
traverse la méditerranée et avec une
fille rare non plus
l'idée des tempes folles courent
hubert et son nuage
jade egypte
demander de l'aide au roi de france
enfin lucas deaux le royaume de france
des pas à soupe il rendit nous à la fin
un cadeau et un cadeau
il
enfin
moi on s'enfuira